let's talk about this uh disney story
because
part of what
i find very interesting all the time is
what disney
does they're a very interesting company
they're incredibly secretive
they don't let anybody in
remember at the end of the florida
project didn't have to shoot that with a
phone because nobody can nobody can film
in disney world there's never been
really a good disney documentary right
right he's never been a dark disney and
you know [ __ ] goes down but you know you
know what i mean
i get a bad feeling from disney world i
have some jokes in my act about it i
don't
like it i don't like it
and it doesn't mean that i don't
recognize its contributions
to the american cultural landscape i
don't really
you know not a ton of them
but
it's it's a disease
kind of it's a sickness
you know
and i don't and i don't know what can be
done about it because people adore it i
even respect
people that love it and people like it
and
it's it's
this eternal
peter pan syndrome
uh that that people have people
people really
enjoy their childhoods
and if if they feel that they've been
slighted in any way during their
childhood or if they've missed anything
they have to continually make up for it
all the time that's why they had these
crazy things like the adult uh summer
camps where people that didn't get a
chance to go to summer camp would then
go as an adult
and instead of going well i'm not going
to get everything out of life you can't
get everything you want you can't have
every experience some people are unable
to admit that they just missed out on so
you can't go back to college at a
certain age it's not the experience you
would have had right but disney world
doesn't seem to be like that people just
connect with it at any age and they just
feel and it's it's odd and whatever and
and and
and so now these these people who are
again they're unwell
they're not well people
but
something is happening now where they're
they're be there they're marketing to
them
and they're they're god help us now
there are disney communities
explain that to people so it's a new
master plan community and they're going
to do it out in uh out in the coachella
valley where walt disney famously lived
out there but this is going to be in
california in california yeah this is
going to be you're a part of disney all
the time so the the water is going to be
that crystal blue turquoise somehow
constantly flowing through the river
here's here's what it says here have you
ever visited a disney theme park resort
with its perfectly manicured and clean
scrubbed grounds by the way that's not
true
a lot in a lot of the cases
but listen listen to even how sick the
article sounds
have you ever visited a disney theme
park resort with its perfectly manicured
and clean scrubbed ground whimsical yet
reassuring architecture why use the word
reassuring
do you see how sick it is do you see how
sick it is
reassuring what it what are you
what do you need to be reassured of
through the architecture
okay
clean scrub grounds whimsical yet
reassuring architecture
chirpy employees and general sense of
cheery optimism and thought
how great would it be
if you could take a permanent residence
there
that's the sort of idea behind the mouse
house's latest venture disney branded
master planned home communities god help
us
today the company announced
story living by disney again
the the coupling of words
story
living
fills me with a sense of dread
story living by disney i'm scared about
what the next few lines of this will be
which will be a part of the same
division that oversees its theme parks
disney cruise line
and other experiences the first
community which would be known as cotino
because it's by coachella which is the
fairgrounds out in the desert by palm
springs where all these rich kids go
dress like native americans your
headdresses in dumali and jump around to
21 pilots
now
by the way
this may be a better use of the desert
than that
let me not judge it's kind of a
throwaway part of the world over there
it's pretty
uh
just a bunch of people so the first
community which would be known as cotino
and include about 1900 housing units
will be in the palm springs city of
rancho mirage california i'm getting
scared now i'm 10 because we're about to
cover something in hamptons i'm very
very scared about what's happening here
this is not good palm springs if you've
ever been out there is a [ __ ] cool
community 1950s this old mid-century
modern homes
old cars
really cool
history there's a lot of [ __ ]
hollywood you know famous old hollywood
sinatra and all this [ __ ]
i'm i'm a little worried now that some
that cotino
is about to open ace a community for
sick
i'm gonna tell you right now
there is a mobile home park in florida
full of pedophiles
okay
i'm telling you right now
between having to live there or cotino
i'm torn
quote there's incredible demand for all
things disney our fans continue to look
for new ways to engage with us
to keep disney as part of their lives
says josh diamaro chairman of disney
parks experiences and products
at the branded communities he had you
could be part of disney all the time
wouldn't it get
wouldn't it get a little sick
don't you think you'd get sick of it
on day i don't know
48
maybe
maybe would take these [ __ ]
to like month three
you know the end but don't
don't you think
eventually you'd say to yourself oh i've
had enough
as for the story living name this is
truly chilling it's chilling
i was talking to a guy once
i forget but i think it was on grindr it
might have been on craigslist it was
very
it's a long time ago and i said
something to him
and he said i a chill ran down my spine
which wasn't good
i don't know what i said but he said it
a chill just ran down my spine but then
he stopped talking to me i think it was
bad
as for the story living name
communities will capitalize on the
company's sense of storytelling and
place making instead of telling mickey
mouse tales however they will focus on
the culture history experience food and
other attributes of the places in which
they will be built
coachella
plans call for a centerpiece lagoon with
a beach that will be accessible to
members of the community's private club
every single element of these
communities will be steeped in a story
the residence he says will be active
participants in the stories
what
i don't even know what that means
what does that even mean i don't know
they have an ad here for it let's watch
this ad we can legally play this because
it's this is sick okay here we go if i'm
telling you right now
if if if you were going
if this excites you in the least
you have very
deep
problems
if there's anything about this if if
you're responding to this in any other
way then what is appropriate which is a
proportional
sense of horror and fear
i'm afraid
how many areas will they ruin with this
oh god i'm afraid and by the way
dizzy wait till
marvel
gets involved hey who likes batman
you want to live with spider-man all the
time
and maybe it's dc don't at me i don't
give a [ __ ] i'm saying when disney
starts these fantasy communities for
sick [ __ ] who just want to live in a
[ __ ] uh movie for the rest of their
lives all of these mega corporations are
they're just gonna build a big nike town
and everyone's gonna be walking around
to dump sneakers i'm telling you it's
trouble troubles are brewing and if you
don't see these trends for what they are
if you don't see these trends as a
massive problem
it is
i can't help you
if you don't think if you think it's a
good idea for disney to build
communities
a corporation like disney world to build
communities that look like movies for
people to pretend to be in a movie all
day
if you think that's a good idea then i
can't help you let's watch the ad
now disney storytelling and world famous
disney service
inspire something new i'll take you
there charming home communities where
the story is all about
you
story living by disney
[Music]
i can't wait till the first guy kills
his wife and they go well this wasn't
part of the story
i'm telling you man it's disturbing
because it's only the beginning right
i mean it's only the beginning what
about buckys they'll have a community
too probably buckies why not
the big what is it a beaver yeah it's a
big beaver yeah the big walmart beaver
that everybody loves bucky's it's a big
walmart type of store with a beaver why
not have a bucky's plan community
bucky's beaver where instead of water in
the fall it's corn syrup
i'm telling you man
this is the beginning
of corporations
designing communities
um
and by the way blackrock all these guys
they'll get in bed with this they go
yeah you can rent
you can start you can rent here and then
eventually
some of cotino's neighborhoods will be
designed for residents 55 and older
a market which disney seems especially
interested in
families with young children and people
of all ages will be able to purchase
properties
you think there'll be a hood
you think there'll be a rough area in
disney
like do you think cotino will have a
hood
you think there'll be a rough area in
the disney community i hope so
you think it'll be any area in the
disney community where they'll just open
air drug markets fentanyl
needles people getting shot
quote baby boomers are moving into
retirement they're going to be moving
into retirement communities that's true
says daryl fairweather chief economist
for seattle-based real estate brokerage
redfin
why not have it be a disney branded
retirement community oh i don't know
daryl [ __ ] common sense
taste decency dignity daryl if you heard
any of those words
have you [ __ ]
ever come in contact with any of those
concepts perhaps google them why not
have it be a disney branded retirement
community i don't know because hopefully
not every elderly person is [ __ ]
insane
disney world should be a four day thing
you put mickey mouse yours on grandma
grandpa it's hot they take naps you have
a [ __ ] mickey waffle and you get the
[ __ ] out of there you don't live there
for the rest of your life you sick [ __ ]
how much do you want to give to how much
do you want to give this corporation
their movies aren't even that good how
much do you want to give these people
how would you want to get this nazi in
his [ __ ] cartoons
how many pounds of flesh must you
deliver them
proof of vaccination is no longer
required to get into disney park well
that's nice
says that amenities will include live
entertainment wellness programming and
seminars
plans call for centerpiece lagoon yeah
we went over that
there will be public components of
cotino as well including a hotel
and entertainment dining and here's what
disturbs you about it people are gonna
love it oh yeah uh people i mean
are i mean
people are gonna love it so much and
this is what scares me
they're gonna go [ __ ] palm springs all
that history and [ __ ] it i want to go to
cotino
a community built 15 minutes ago by
corporate psychopaths
and i i i want to visit cotino because
my cousin just moved there they're doing
they're story living in cotino what's
that well living's not enough
see that's how they came up with story
living an executive sat in a room and
went living's not enough
people need a story
we got to give them a story
while can't they create their own
stories
we thought they could but apparently
they can't that's why they keep coming
back to our [ __ ] park
so we've created a story for them we've
built a community where the water is uh
blue it's like gatorade colored
nothing's real everything's ugly and
neon and brightly colored and everyone's
happy in every moment of the day no
matter who's getting raped everybody's
thrilled no matter how diseased and drug
addicted and no matter the famine that's
going on outside of these gates they're
chirpy and happy cause we think disney
should be about happiness no matter what
the hell is going on we don't care
outside of cotino the world will be
going to hell in a handbasket but we put
up those gates and put a lot of guys
with guns outside and inside it's all
mickey waffles and smiles because it's
cotino now if it works it won't stop
with disney it will expand other
carl's jr will have a community
i'm telling you all of these
corporations they will keep doing this
they will realize that people need their
entire lives to be planned and managed
for them
and and they will try to provide people
some refuge from the horrors of
existence by creating these serene
corporate environments of like-minded
people and you're going to live around
all these people who saw lady in the
[ __ ] and it had such an effect on them
that they never wanted to do anything
else with their life and they're gonna
live in these places and it will never
it's not gonna stop with disney disney
will be the most successful and the
biggest but then other other companies
are going to start to do this as well
all the [ __ ] dc and marvel and all
that comic book [ __ ]
despite bearing its name disney will not
own the communities or be the developer
of record
nor will it be building or selling the
homes it will be partnering with third
parties to handle those functions
because they want to keep their hands
off it for when it gets sticky right
right
however disney's fabled imagineers the
band of creatives who bring the parks
animatronic pirates to life will have a
hand to design and continue and future
community as for the public face of the
communities disney will manage the
marketing and sales efforts and once the
communities are up and running it's
quote cast members disney speak for
employees cast members
cast members
oh is that person being nice to me no
they're it's uh they're an actor it's
they're cast
oh i like living is that what it's gonna
be it's gonna be like the beginning of
beauty and beast bonjour bonjour welcome
to starbucks in cotino
would you like a coffee how are you
your daughter's cutting herself she has
issues
but don't worry it's the smiles incotina
bonjour bonjour my wife has cancer
it's happy time
we're happy no matter what
turns out that the legendary founder of
the company owned a home and frequented
the coachella valley region in which
cotino will be located
walt disney treated the area like his
creative oasis says michael hundren
executive producer with walt disney
imagineering we love our residents to
treat this as their creative oasis and
explore the next chapter of their lives
quote walt disney loved the coachella
valley because of the weather and famous
lack of jews
odd that they would put that
strange
according to redfin disney will tightly
control the communities that could bring
both pros and cons to homeowners there
would okay ready there wouldn't be a
quote rowdy bar down the street or
obnoxious new music from your neighbor
yeah of course
you're buying in to a complete it's
completely gonna be controlled but it
would come at the cost of your own
personal freedom that wouldn't sit well
with everybody but some disney devotees
who like the company's brand and values
would welcome the careful curation of
the community by the way the personal
freedom giving that'll people will love
that
they don't care
i love when people go yeah it's not
going to be for everybody to complete uh
surrendering in their personal fruit
well by the way over the last two years
it's been for a lot of people
i mean
it's interesting because they're
creating a community
it's a corporation
uh with obviously they've created an
entire world of cartoon animals
and cartoons and
famous films and music
and they are saying people let come live
in that world and not the real world
where there might be a rowdy bar or your
neighbor might have music leave that
world come live in our world that's
completely curated and everybody's nice
to you not because you're a good person
or you deserve it it's because they are
cast members in a movie that we are
making which you will be the star of if
you buy our [ __ ] house for however
much it's going to be
well disney had grand ambitions to
develop a working city with residents
what kind of residence walt
which would have showcased the latest
technology because he was a nazi that's
why that's funny so when i say what kind
of residence waltz it's a nazis
he dubbed the project epcot which stood
for experimental prototype community of
tomorrow what did that mean walt
after his death at 66 disney's
successors re-interpreted his vision as
a theme park epcot that exists tonight
well i mean here's the thing we wish
them all well right i mean uh this is
very disturbing and i'm glad we got into
this because i'm uh uh very bothered by
this but like anything else i'm not
gonna you know what am i gonna be able
to do
we'll probably be eating they're in the
catina steakhouse it won't be bad
i'll be in katina like anyone else
eating ice cream
people go hey remember when you i said
shut up
i'm just sitting there eating a big
mickey sundae it's 112 degrees in cutino
maybe i'll live in cottino
who gives a [ __ ] anymore what's the
point
it's the point of anything
if they're all happy maybe it works
who am i to say
come on this [ __ ] show and i yell
about people people just want to be
brainwashed until they [ __ ] go in the
ground
let them
what's the problem